(phone ringing)
(phone being hung up)
("Pemain Bola" by Rasela)
(airplane engine roars)
- Breaking news,
major corruption
crime time going down.
- His credibility has
already been questioned
Sunday, the Football
Association said
they are continuing to apply--
(singing in foreign language)
- This is not good enough!
(speaking in foreign language)
(chanting)
(camera shutter clicking)
(airplane engines roaring)
(traffic rumbling)
- From first here in
the five teams we're
interested, it whittled
its way down to two.
And then about a week ago,
finally, one came
forward and said,
"Right, we're ready to sign you.
"Come out here and let's talk."
Nice to meet you, your name?
(speaking faintly)
Simon.
I'm signing for a full year.
Could sign for longer,
but to be honest,
contract's over a year
out here is not worth
the paper it's written on.
If something goes
wrong out here,
you only get a couple of
months to walk away anyway, so.
But it does give you the
option after 12 months
that if you do do really well,
you can ask for more money
and renegotiate your contract.
I'm very pleased to be
sitting here as head coach
of Mitra Kukar as we
go into a mew season.
You know, they'll be
some ups and downs
along the way, I'm sure.
They're will be
injuries, suspensions,
and referees this season
that we'll all talk about.
But at the end of the
day, everything we
do from here on in
is about winning.
(clapping)
(happy dance music)
(jazz music)
- Where do you begin with the
problem of Indonesian football?
There's been decade and
decades of scandals,
corruption, fans dying
watching the game,
violence in the
game, the usage of
governmental funding which
makes it very political,
which makes it very easy for
match fixing to take place.
That's been going
on for decades, and
decades, and decades.
- Players, officials,
staff, they actually
don't get paid on
time, you know?
And it's not like two
or three days delay,
it's like talking about
without three to eight months.
Some players can't really
support their family
anymore, and somebody
come, okay would you
like to give up a gave
for just 10,000 dollars?
I mean, it's very
easy for them to take.
I mean, you don't
get paid, you get
an easy money, which
one do you take?
(electric tones)
- [Female] Attention please.
Please give way to
the line T passengers.
- That's Wilson's voice.
- [Male] Well how does,
how much money is
needed to ensure that
Mali do what you say, Willy?
Yes.
- Okay, it ends here,
there are others.
It's in my book,
all the transcripts
that we put in the book
and how much betting
for a game, one million for the
2010 World Cup
warmup qualifiers.
So it's crazy man,
it's big money.
Fixing is not only for gambling,
not only for money, but
it could be for honor,
it can be for political
ends and so on.
There are many dimensions
to match fixing,
and it depends on what
you want to get out of it.
- [Simon] Good, good!
Now run!
Run better!
Use balls this time.
(yelling in foreign language)
- Good!
Ah!
Not good enough!
Shoot the gate, good!
Longer!
No physio, no system
manager, no goal
keeper coach, yeah disappointing
with the organization
to be honest
you can only work with
the tools you're given.
I make you tired.
I make you.
Then I make you pass.
Let's just say it
needs to improve.
It needs to improve
if this is gonna
be a challenging
club in Indonesia.
They're signing
a lot of players,
so to be honest, the
pressure on me is ramping up.
In Indonesia a
week, my first time
working at this level
in the country, and
yeah the manager's
saying to me now,
he expects to win the league.
As you do I suppose, you
spend that much money,
but it's just part
and parcel with it.
This is something I
forget all the time.
They pray before the game.
There's me chatting away
through their prayer,
and they're all waiting
for me to stop talking.
So I gotta get used to that.
Can't work out, well.
It's certainly not
Catholic, so I'm
not sure what religion
it is, to be honest.
- Coaches have to
overcome so many problems
here that other coaches
in Europe don't have to.
Factors that has nothing
to do with football
that actually sums up
whether you're successful
or not, you know.
Foreigners, whether
in football or not,
they have to adjust, and
they just have to go with it.
But you do need a thick skin.
Yeah in terms of match
fixing, that it is happening
and that's happening
very, very often.
And years after years,
continuously, that is a fact.
(quiet rhythmic music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(national anthems play)
- You see that, but you
just cannot prove that.
You just cannot prove that.
And you will have a
hunch, you will notice it,
you will think
about it, it's just,
this is a case, this
gonna be a case,
but you just cannot prove it.
In a situation like a
match fixing and stuff,
the official will
not be approached.
(cheering)
(singing in foreign language)
(rhythmic percussion music)
(chanting in foreign language)
- Make them run.
Okay?
You play with a little
bit of common sense,
if you lose ball, lose
ball, don't chase.
Get back in, have
shape, say come on then.
Okay, conserve
energy in defense.
Use energy going forward.
(whistle blows)
Bobby, come and get
the ball, Bobby.
(shouting in foreign language)
Good, well done.
Advantage, we have the ball.
Good, Lee.
Oh he skips past the,
goal to blue!
(cheering)
(whistle blowing)
Come on, let's pick
up, quicker quicker!
(shouting)
(whistle blows)
Scared shitless.
Zero-zero, I'd be, hm.
But we lost to a shit team.
They're not good
enough to beat us.
But they have.
Now understand one thing,
my teams do not stop.
You play for my team,
you fight until 94th,
95th, 96th minute, you
don't just slow down.
But today was more
about me learning,
and them learning about me.
And less really
about the result.
I thought the team we played
against were good team,
but I think what we
showed, we showed that
we have a lot of
ability, and we will
get better and
better and better.
Today was just about learning.
It was about understanding, so
I'm happy.
I don't like to lose,
never like to lose, but
as far as what I've
taken away from the game,
I learned an awful lot
about the players today.
So that's good.
- [TV Announcer] Vietnam
attacking to go to a right
against the Philippines.
- I've been plucked
from relative obscurity
in Ryman South and been
given an opportunity
at the national team
of the Philippines.
And succeeding with
that and taking them
to their highest
fee for rankings
they've ever been
in their history,
classic underdog story.
I'm not a name, I'm not
a Premiership Manager,
I've not worked in
England at a particularly
high level, but I've
been given an opportunity
and I'm hugely
thankful for everyone
that just wanted me to do well.
It was an amazing feeling to
come out of that with success.
- [Game Announcer]
Cristian with the hustle,
could this be a goal?
Yes, the Philippines
have scored.
- You know there's guys
who work first team
coaches in the
Premiership, they've never
been anywhere near
a national team.
I'd like to think
I'll get another
international team
job eventually, but
I need to take advantage
of the opportunity
that was given to me.
And I need to, like I say,
push it as hard as I can
to make a career out of it.
- [Game Announcer]
Wonderful, wonderful
victory for the Philippines.
The right results.
We are best ever--
- When Simon, first
went to the Philippines,
football was not
a popular sport.
They didn't have
their own league.
their own stadium.
They had a national team
that weren't competitive.
Simon came in and
changed all that.
You know that's gonna be
probably one of the biggest
successes of his whole career.
It's tough, it's not easy.
And sometimes
we might take,
niggle at each other,
and take things
out on each other
'cause there isn't
really anyone else that.
You know when you're
at home, you've got
your family, you've got friends,
you've got a massive
support network.
But here, Simon and I
literally vent at each other.
Simon's like oh,
we're on the same team.
We are, but it's difficult.
(slow dramatic music)
(whistle blowing)
(thunder)
- Down to the match fixing
or arranging a game,
it's all possible
because players
might decide just to do anything
to get something for himself.
Small bonuses to live, you know?
So yeah we did
just a small tryout
to see how simple or easy it is
actually maybe to
buy a player, or
to give some money out
for him to do something
in a game, you know?
So we were asking them,
this particular player,
we're talking about the
goal keeper over here.
We have three schemes for him.
Whenever he get the
first ball in the game,
he will just kick it out,
to the center, anywhere,
for a throw out.
The second one is
to, is just to fake
an injury in the last
10 minutes of the game.
Basically asking
for substitution.
Now if the coach has used
his three substitution,
and they're in winning position,
we'll ask him to let
the goal in, basically.
Only in winning position, yeah?
We just wanna see
whether it works or not.
- I'm sure you wanna prove
that it can be done easily.
We've been getting proof
from the horse's
mouth in terms of
secretly recorded conversations,
SMSs,
WhatsApp.
But fixing a game?
I think is a bit too much.
Yeah?
Too ballsy, man
(singing in foreign language)
- If you look out
and see how happy
the fans are, you know, they're
supporting their club
all the way to the end,
they're ready to
die for the club,
for the players.
At the end, the club themself,
or the players,
some of them just
basically betrayed 'em.
You know, betrayed them.
(singing in foreign language)
- Indonesia has
got the best fans,
they're just amazingly loyal.
And they just long for
their national team
to win and be successful,
and I just don't see
this as just soccer.
You have to understand,
soccer is just
a mirror or what goes on
throughout the country
at any level.
(tonal music)
- September 2010 when
my boss asked me to
look into, do a story
of Togo playing Bahrain,
it turned out that the Togo
team was a fake one, and
after asking
the Bahrain side who
organized the match
they told us it was a
company in Singapore
called Football For You.
We realized that it belonged
to one Wilson Raj Perumal.
The company was a
front, it didn't exist,
and we realized
that this could be
something bigger, you know?
- As a coach, it's
very frustrating if you
see things happening
that are not normal.
And you cannot actually
say, oh that's was
match fixing because they
don't do it that obviously.
There are some people
that don't wanna do that,
some referees, but
it's got so bad that
some managers
actually give money
just so that the referees
don't ref against them.
You ref fair, here's some
money for you to ref fair.
You know, that just is horrible.
As a coach it's just,
why do you do that?
Why do you train?
Why you pick players?
Why you keep players happy?
Why do you make
amazing speeches,
like "Braveheart" speeches
before a game, you know?
It's pointless.
You know, why do you study
leadership and psychology?
Why do you bother
scouting how do they play
and coming up with
appropriate tactics?
And why bother all of that
if in the 80th minute,
the referee just
says penalty kick?
(tonal music)
(chopper blades whirring)
- Oni has promised bonus
for win today.
Today win bonus.
So you have every incentive
to win, more money.
More fast cars and cheap women.
Didn't get that.
Stand up, be big, strong.
Under 21s, Mitra Kukar.
Strong.
Okay, always stay in
front, in front, in front.
(huddle cheer in
foreign language)
(exciting techno music)
This is one of the
things that annoy me.
Match officials cutting corners.
He should have done this before.
You got the players out
standing in the heat,
out of the dressing room,
and now he's talking to them.
Some fucking self-important
match official.
He should have been
in the dressing room
20 minutes before
checking players
and players names
that match the shirts.
Not coming out here
and doing it while
all the players are
now cooling down
'cause they're out here.
They just stretched and now
they're standing waiting
for some old codger to
sort himself out and read
names off a list.
There you go.
Thank you.
Great stuff.
(shouting)
(whistle blowing)
Well done, Miru, well done.
Well done.
Closer, closer.
Go on, run, run, run!
No, no, no.
It's out!
Hey!
Can I have any fines?
(shouting)
What's this about, eh?
Like that?
What's this about?
This is a friendly.
- Yes, this is.
- This is not good enough.
- Yes, yes, yes, okay.
- Anyone else about
this or is it just me?
(tense music)
Okay, just stop, just
stop, just stop and listen.
Okay?
Five minutes, just
stop and listen,
then we can go, no problem.
If you think that
performance is gonna
win us the league, you've
got another thing coming.
You got bullied, bullied,
by 22 21 year old kids.
You're professional
footballers earning good money,
and you're oh.
Not tackling, run past.
You think we will win like this?
You think we win games?
No fucking heart!
No heart!
Just oh okay.
Oh, eh, okay okay.
Lee goes in, gets a
fucking elbow in the head.
That's how much
they want to win.
I'm not happy in the slightest
about how we got bullied.
Every tackle (weak whimper).
Who hit someone?
If you think that is enough,
then that's not.
Concentrate.
Okay?
Understand?
Good.
Okay.
(rainfall pattering)
(thunder)
- The first time I
met Simon McMenemy,
was on a semi-final
IFF 2010 in Jakarta.
After the Philippine's
games and he become sort of
you know, media darling.
Like them and people like him.
And before you know it, become
the coach of Mitra Kukar.
- My close friends
think, admire me for
making the decision
to give up my job and
to come with Simon
to follow his dream.
I mean, it's a holiday
for the first month,
maybe two months
you're out here,
it feels like a holiday.
The longer you're here,
the more people realize that
actually this is your life.
Giving up working two jobs,
giving up seeing my friends
and going to all the way to
the other side of the world
and not really doing
anything was really hard.
(soft rhythmic music)
- We have Hamkah who's
national team center back.
The John Terry of
Indonesian football.
And we got Bustomi who
is the Paul Scholes
of Indonesian football.
And we're still
waiting for two more
under 23 national team players
and one more foreign
center forward.
So it's starting to
get quite exciting now.
Starting to see the
squad kind of come
together and it's all, it's
all looking rather good.
- (foreign language)
make sure it different.
- [Male] Yeah, okay.
(laughter)
- What's this?
Menu?
- [Male] No, no.
- Pshh.
(cheering)
(traffic humming)
- So first just some,
just a friendly talk,
just how he is
and who's playing,
where he's playing what
he's doing and everything.
And then I'm
explaining to the owner
that I need him to
do something for me.
Here is a goal, just for
that I get the money?
And then he asks
where are you now.
So I say I'm in Jakarta
and I'll talk to you in detail.
(chiming music)
- I know that as of May 2014,
there had been attempts
to fix two teams,
two matches in the
Indonesian Football League.
(dialing tones)
Just listen.
This is a three way
conversation.
(call in foreign language)
So he mentioned the
two teams here.
(call in foreign language)
Big money, big money.
everybody make big money.
Yeah.
So if you tell me that
it's not happening,
people are too
afraid to do things, no.
Some people are still in the
business and they will do.
Do.
It's almost like a
business transaction.
You wanna make money,
I wanna make money too.
So yeah, it's business.
(phone ringing)
- [Male] So what
time can we meet him?
So tonight?
Okay.
(slow atmospheric music)
- We're actually offering
him a certain amount
of cash, but then he said well,
after delay, he will take the
money after he's doing a job.
For me that's always
just like well you know,
it's kind of risky, but
he only say no to the
pos-si-ja-sec later.
It's not actually
technically no,
but just like not
now, just later.
But the way he
took the question,
the way he answer it,
the way he talk about it,
it's in a very
normal, relaxed way.
You know, he become a
little bit uncomfortable
in some stage, but
I think it's because
of the place where we
are, it's in public.
Well I think he just didn't
see it coming from me.
(horn music)
(boat motor running)
(muffled shouting)
- Oh, easy.
This looks like it's just
dropped out of Europe somewhere.
It's Europe but it
you can tell it's Asia
at the same time because
it's not looked after.
It's five years
old and it's dirty.
And this is what
frustrates me so much
about Asian football
is they build
these amazing stadiums like
this which is incredible
considering we're in
the middle of the jungle
three hours from
the nearest airport.
They build a stadium like
this and then just let it rot.
Love to see it full,
it just very rarely is.
- So what happens a lot
is that
the
mayor appoints a manager
that was involved
in his election campaign.
And so the manager
uses the club as a
platform to make money.
And so what he does
is he appoints a coach
and he gets a cut from the
coach, a certain million,
and every player he appoints,
you get a cut from the players.
And coaches sometimes
do that as well,
so the coaches and the
managers work together.
And the coach get a cut and
the manager get a bigger cut.
(laughs) it's just, you know,
it's funny, but it's
so sad, you know.
- If you can't win,
you might as well lose.
And if you lose, hopefully you
can lose by such a scoreline.
Now if it's been
agreed that that would
be the scoreline,
then the match fixer
with the information, he will go
to his betting operations,
illegal betting operations,
and inform his
superiors that the game
is gonna turn out this way.
So with that knowledge
of the scoreline,
they will bet
whatever amount
that would not
raise any suspicion.
Of course at the top,
you have one boss,
or maybe the most two.
They are the ones who will
finance the operations.
Below that you have the runners
or even the lieutenants who will
direct the play at
the ground level.
There are, of course,
people on the ground
who need to speak
to the players,
to the officials
to corrupt them,
and these guys are
the ones that have
direct contact with the players.
And they will call
football players
like 15, 16 years old,
telling them like hey,
this is today's
football, this is the
smart way of playing football.
You'll lose the
game, yes, but you'll
have something in your pocket.
For a guy that young,
he might not know
the consequences, but
that's how they work.
They tell them that this
is today's smart football.
(phone ringing)
- Simon actually got told
that a referee had
phoned the club,
said if you wanna guarantee
a win it's gonna cost you
however much.
Someone told Simon,
and Simon was just
not happy.
And he spoke to the owner.
And the owner was
like, oh well, you know
sometimes you have
to in order to win.
And Simon's like no.
We're not doing that,
not while I'm head coach.
You know, I'm not
being any part of that.
And the owner was
like oh no, no, yes,
of course no, no we're not
part of that and everything.
It was completely brushed
aside and forgotten
and it wasn't that,
but then Simon's
going into that
game thinking well
the other head coach
has probably had
exactly the same phone call.
I don't know if he
said yes or not.
So you could be going in there,
all the preparation in
the world, not knowing.
(laughing)
- Okay, we go, we go.
(rhythmic drum music)
(shouting)
(muffled cheering)
We still got one game
after this to go,
and that's away in Papua.
That'll be a tough
game, but it's
important you win
your home games.
So we've gotta attempt
three points today
to make sure that
we can go to Papua,
have a good fight.
And if we take the
three points there,
that puts us at 33,
three behind the leader,
so fingers crossed
that'll be enough.
- Okay coach, can you talk about
the last condition
from your team?
- The team's in
very good condition.
We have two players
who've come back
from injury today, so we
have no injury problems.
Everyone is 100% fit.
Everyone very confident
in the game today.
I just get their team sheet.
They have four substitutes.
They can't even name
seven substitutes.
That tells you
they're struggling.
That tells you they're
struggling with injuries.
struggling with suspensions.
So that means from minute
one you get at them.
You don't let them out.
You don't give them a break.
The first tackle, the
first head up, you win.
But we batter then, batter them,
batter them, batter them.
Three points puts you 3rd.
We have to take care
of business today.
(huddle cheer in
foreign language)
(lively music)
(cheering)
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
(muffled commentating)
(cheering)
This team have come
here to defend.
They've not come
here to go forward.
here to score goals.
For them, it's
damage limitation.
If they can come away with
a zero-zero, they're happy.
You get one goal, they crumble.
They finish.
But you have to
get that one goal.
And we keep the pressure
in the final third.
'Cause eventually they'll crack.
They are not good
enough defensively
to handle you through
the whole game.
(muffled commentating)
(cheering)
That is a really, really
difficult one to take.
To dominate the game that much.
For one reason or another,
there was no luck with us today.
Nothing fell.
We've now got to go to Papua,
travel two days,
drive in a bus, stay
in a crappy hotel,
we've got to go to Papua
and take three points.
(new age music)
(crowd chattering)
- [Male] What the?
But you've got to be joking.
(horn blows)
(cheering)
(horn blowing)
(muffled speaking
in foreign language)
(cheering)
(horn blowing)
(camera shutter)
(dramatic music)
- Because he misses
all the substitutions,
so I cannot fake an injury.
But because we talked about that
me letting a goal in,
then I did that, just.
And just confirming
the what's up.
The game was very fishy
from the beginning to the end.
With all the red card injuries,
the goals and how
it was defended,
how it was being
scored, and so on.
So yeah.
I think there's something else
happening in that game.
After the game, you
know, I call him.
This time, he arrange
a place to meet
in a coffee shop in a mall,
in one of the cafe there.
So we get there,
we have coffee, and
then I try to offer
the envelope, you know?
But he said he didn't
wanna take it then.
I think it's mostly because
it's very crowded place.
He doesn't want
people to see that
there is a transaction going on.
Then we grab a cab.
And then we just drove away.
In the cab, where it's only
me and him and the driver,
I handed over the
money and he took it.
No question, he
just took it and say
oh great man, thanks.
You know, this is
like a bonus, and
it's awesome, and
it's a blessing.
Like, great thank you.
In the back of my
head, I think he was
kind of hoping
that in the future
I would do that
same again to him.
(soft chiming music)
(train horn)
You would like to interview him,
and ask him to speak
in front of a camera.
I mean with guarantee all
his safety and everything,
but he refuse it.
I think the main
reason that he didn't
wanna talk in front of
camera is basically safety.
If that is your life,
and suddenly you
are saying that you're
part of a scheme
and you're doing that,
and you're on camera.
And forever'll
haunt you, you know?
- [Male] So you not got paid,
you not get paid
for three months,
four months, and someone
gives you money, you say no?
- Yeah we were thinking,
I was thinking first,
it's good to show
him the footage.
Like say hey man,
you see, you said
I've never taken the
money, but here you are.
And you did take it.
But at the end,
we decided not to
because it's also just
pure for his safety first.
Or the second, that
he will go and report
to someone and we
will be in trouble.
(running feet)
(whistling)
(yelling)
- I've not heard
anything about this.
I don't know.
All good?
- [Male] We're given the sack.
- [Simon] What?
Fuck off.
Okay, which one?
(muffled speaking)
Timing could been better.
The club has decided
that last night's loss
wasn't good enough, and that
in order for the
club to develop,
they need to bring
in new head coach.
(somber music)
Um.
I just get you together
for last time.
Some of you know, some
of you don't know.
Last night management
have meeting,
and they decide that
best for Mitra Kukar that
I not continue as coach
or Darren not continue as coach.
I don't know what
happens from here.
For you guys, I'm sure you
will be all looked after.
With me, nothing
is ever personal.
Everything is always football.
I said to you first
day of season,
I will put the best
11 players I have
in my opinion on
the football field.
And if players get left
out, players get left out.
I must deal with that.
But you will only ever got
left out for football reason,
never for personal reason.
You must believe
that to be true.
Thank you.
- I go home
and I talk
to my boss
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- One you coach in Myanmar.
- Alright, if they
won, they won.
Just stay in touch, let me know.
Right, we go.
(speaking in foreign language)
(somber music)
(muffled singing)
Leaving the club
fourth in the league,
half a season done.
My target was fifth.
Just three weeks
ago, they changed
the target.
I had a meeting
with the president,
and the president said
the last four games,
the club want me to
take eight points.
- But they didn't
say what would happen
if you didn't get
eight points.
- No, they but.
- They didn't say get eight
points or we're gonna sack you.
They just, that
was something that
they wanted you to aim for.
So clear goals weren't set,
and they're moving the goalpost
just because suddenly a team
that they thought would,
they'd be happy finishing
fifth or doing well,
so they've decided that actually
they wanna be greedy
and try and get higher.
Which is fair
enough, but you can't
just sack the coach
if they haven't.
- Well, they can and they have.
- Well, okay
they have.
- This is the way.
But that's Indonesia.
- They can.
- You play a certain formation
and it's not usual, or you put
a player out of position
which is something
you do out of,
because it's
necessary tactically.
They don't understand
it, and they
actually try to
tell you who should
be playing, who
should not be playing.
That's a big turn off
as a coach, you know?
Either you trust
me or you don't.
You trust me, and if
it doesn't go well,
you blame me, fine.
That's why I don't
wanna coach right now.
(lively drumming music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Today we're playing
Surabaya Bhayankar United.
I mean man, I don't even
know their name anymore.
They've been changing
it a lot this year.
It's a team owned by police
force in Indonesia, so
I'm gonna expect a
lot of police support
in the stadium today.
(speaking in foreign language)
Well, I think with
Simon McMenemy,
I think he got a culture shock,
that's how I see it, you know?
He come with amazing
football strategy and
tactics and game
plan, but I think
he missed something
about the culture.
If Simon probably
understand that
and managed to dig into that,
I think he will do
really good over here.
'Cause I mean he
already, people like him.
- Without doubt, the
most enjoyable part
of this job is standing in front
of so many people every week.
Standing in front of
so many crazy fans
appreciating the
passion for your team
and against your team.
Just witnessing people
going mad over goals and
penalties and free kicks.
The pinnacle of the
last three years was
the two semi-finals in
the Bung Karno in Jakarta
in front of 90
thousand people and
an estimated TV audience of,
I don't know, 400,
500 million people
across South-East Asia.
You can work a lifetime and
not get that opportunity.
And to have represented a
country at the same time,
to stand as a head coach
with a country behind you.
And listening to
the national anthem,
and knowing that the
whole country's at home
willing you on, is an
incredible feeling.
(cheering)
(shouting in foreign language)
- Maybe in the last
four years or five years
we had the publicity,
and the (foreign word)
or match fixing has risen
to what it is today.
There will be people who
are naturally skeptical
of what they're
seeing on the screen,
on the field, and
they will question
like, is this a fixed match?
So yeah, we may have
lost a few souls
in terms of fans,
but again I think
it's for the better
that the (foreign word)
of matching fixing
is out to show that
the world is trying to
do something about it.
(chanting)
- Match fixing, yeah sure.
Although it's very difficult
to prove, you know it goes on.
Probably with players,
probably with referees.
Probably with owners.
Vietnam, you have
to probably learn,
owners would own three or
four clubs in the same league.
So if the team at the
bottom of the league
needed to three points,
not to get relegated
on the last day of the season,
and they just
happen to be playing
the owner's other
team that's towards
the top of the league, you
can guarantee who wins.
You have to understand what's
going on around football.
You have to understand
the personalities
and the culture around football.
And then you have to
try and slowly work
your own thoughts,
ideas into that mix.
And at the same time
win games of football.
- The biggest thing
you need to do,
number one, you gotta
make a rule that
if you're involved in politics,
you cannot be involved
in clubs or federations.
Simple.
But it's hard to
do it, it's big.
The next step would
be to not allow
government funding for clubs.
Lots of clubs would
die, but it's better
to have a league made
out of 12 healthy clubs
that are not political,
not government funded,
that way you don't mix
politics with football.
That way you take
out the corruption.
And that way you take
out match fixing.
- Then you need hunters
like these guys,
who go around the world, who
behave like match fixers,
in terms of searching
out targets.
And then when it's
finally time to
affect an arrest, then we open
the local law enforcement.
That's the only way
to chase these guys.
- One thing you
learn about Asia,
is that nothing goes your way,
and that you have to
roll with the punches
and make the best
of every situation.
You have to remember
that you're number one,
and you have to look
out for yourself.
And if you can keep
your morals in tact
while you're doing that,
and that's just a bonus.
- Will it happen in
Europe, in South America,
in other part of
Asian and Africa?
I'm sure the same
things happens,
you just gotta prove it.
The supporters out
there are just giving
all their heart out
to sing, to jump.
If at the end of the game
it being just corrupted,
being fixed, so
what's the point of
having a football game really?
You wanna have a clean game.
(chanting)
("Pemain Bola" by Rasela)
(singing in foreign language)